okay before we get into the rest of the
show for today I do want to mention two
days ago I went to the audience and I
said hey what do you want us to replace
audience questions with number one we're
still doing audience questions on
today's show we actually got a lot of
feedback from the audience saying keep
audience questions we like audience
questions if you do get rid of them
replace it with international news but
overwhelmingly people writing in saying
they want us to keep audience questions
I'm completely open to doing that so I
wanted before we get into the weekend
just to put out there that I am not
married to the idea of getting rid of
audience questions I was worried that we
were sort of running out of material but
a lot of the emails say that people like
the sort of curated hand-picked nature
of audience questions so I'm up for
keeping it but here's my request to you
if you were interested in us keeping
audience questions send me a question or
two because what we're finding is that a
lot of the questions that come up are
questions we've answered in the past
already because we've done so many
hundreds of these over the years so I'm
open to keeping audience questions we're
not making the decision right away but
if you want to see audience questions
stick around definitely let me know but
send in a question or two that we can
add to our roster of available questions
but audience questions today definitely
happening we have a great show we will
have a great interview we are going to
take live calls we have a fantastic
bonus show planned and yes audience
questions on today's program glad you're
with us on this Friday show quick break
back after this